how old were you when you started
believing in God and what stopped you
before I started believing in God when I
was 29 and what stopped me before I
don't know the idea of God is hard to
believe I was brought up with the
psychological significance of the Bible
but not God is real and it's hard to
believe so I didn't believe it before
because it doesn't make any sense but
then when you start believing it it
makes more sense and then the weird
things that happened in your life are
like okay well
science doesn't explain everything
it's God I was 29 and I didn't believe
before because the concept of God is
very difficult to understand I still
don't understand it completely obviously
but at least I believe
that it exists